from each candidate in the same order
that they will speak now
so
well we're about to um find out uh from
our five candidates what they have to
say and um
in only a few weeks one of them will be
leader of the conservative party and
prime minister and our purpose today of
course is to find out which one
if any so i'm going to go over to liz
truss who will make the first opening
statement liz welcome
thanks very much paul and great to see
everybody today
i wasn't brought up as a traditional
conservative
i grew up in paisley i went to school
comprehensive school in leeds and what i
saw at that school is i saw lots of
children being let down
by low educational standards
by
a lack of
expectation and also by a lack of
opportunity
and i just thought that was an
incredible waste so one of the reasons i
want to go into
this job and why i went into politics
is i want this country to be somewhere
where everyone can succeed
regardless of where they're from i want
us to be an aspiration nation that
unleashes opportunity right across this
country but the reality is we've had two
decades of low growth
we haven't seen those opportunities and
we're now facing a major economic crisis
following kovid
and the war of russia
in ukraine and this is why we need a
bold economic policy
we can't just go on with our current
policy
i advocate a major new economic plan we
need to cut taxes particularly things
like national insurance and corporation
tax we need to get people to invest in
the united kingdom
we need to see public spending held
under control
for the future but we also need to
unleash the dynamism of the british
economy
by reforming our regulations by truly
diverging from eu regulations whether
it's solvency ii whether it's mifid we
need to open up opportunities right
across britain
i would set up investment zones low tax
zones around the country to help level
up in a conservative way
i want to see people able to farmers
able to produce food without unnecessary
regulation
and what i want to do is make sure that
we are truly leveling up our country
i'm somebody who can go into the job on
day one i've got a track record of
delivering
whether it's the department of trade
where we secured dozens of trade deals
even though people said it wouldn't be
possible whether at the foreign office
where i've stood up to vladimir putin we
put in some of the toughest sanctions of
anywhere in the world and we've also
dealt with the issue of the northern
ireland protocol resolving a
long-standing issue
what's important is that we deliver on
the promises we made to the british
people
people across the country are struggling
with the cost of living
they need to know that things are going
to be different
and i'm the prime minister who together
with a really strong conservative team
can deliver on the ground from day one
and make that difference
it's not inevitable that kierstarma or
red devi are going to win the next
election in fact i don't think they're
very popular at all
but what we have to do is show momentum
to show we can do things differently to
show we can deliver on the promise of
brexit and really open up these
opportunities and that's what i would
deliver as prime minister thank you
thank you liz and without any more ado
i'm going over to tom toughenhart
good morning
we're conservatives because we believe
in britain
this is the country that we love this is
the country that we serve
but in recent days in recent months
we've seen trust collapse from the
conservative party and from the
government
we need to change
we need a clean start we need a new way
of approaching the country that we
govern and the party that we all serve
because this isn't about us it's not
about us here today
it's about you
it's about the communities that you lead
as activists as councillors as many
other you know many other different
walks of life it's about how you deliver
a different britain
now i believe in britain i fought for
britain and i'm incredibly proud of our
great country
so i'm looking forward to making the
case this evening today and for many
years to come
because what we need to do is not be
just choosing the leader of the
conservative party however important
that is but the leader of our country
who is going to take labour to task on
their epic failures around the country
to take on the snp who are trying to
tear us apart to take on clyde and the
lib dems who are letting down
communities across the uk
but we can only do it we can only do it
if we get a clean start we can only do
it if we restore trust in our government
trust in our party trust in every part
of the united kingdom
because this party
is the natural party of government
because we deliver
we deliver for the british people we
deliver the change that people need and
we know that we need to plan for the
future
because at the moment
the crisis at home the cost of living
the challenges abroad that i've called
out on so many occasions russia and
china that i've been warning about for
years
and now coming home
they're coming home to roost and they're
costing us all and if you want to know
why your fuel bills are high if you want
to know why trust is collapsing
look at the failures that we've had
and the changes that we need because as
conservatives we have never been better
than when we're dynamic margaret
thatcher showed it winston churchill
showed it we are able to deliver change
now i am ready to serve i'm ready to
lead
you know my record of service not just
in the army but in westminster
delivering a change in our foreign
policy delivering change
across our country and that's why i want
to work with you
i want to work with every community
across the united kingdom to deliver a
conservative victory in may 23 in our
councils and of course in 24 in the
general election when we will see
conservatives elected across the united
kingdom we'll do it by leveling up we'll
do it by delivering change we'll do it
by rebuilding trust we can restore pride
in britain we can restore pride in our
party and we could restore pride in our
government
i look forward to serving you
i look forward to returning to service
i'm proud to be standing as your leader
and i look forward to serving as your
prime minister
thanks tom and next up is kemi bajang
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen i
put myself forward to be our party
leader to tell the truth but this
afternoon i want to tell you
who i am and let you see what sort of
person i am and why i'm putting myself
forward to be the leader and to be the
prime minister of our country
i'm an engineer and a problem solver and
unlike others i don't promise things
without a plan to deliver them
and my campaign has been from the heart
because i care i care about you i care
about our party and i care about our
country our party members work hard
every day and i want to acknowledge the
service that you give in good times and
bad and also apologize for all the
things that we have done in westminster
that have left so many of you down i've
been a member of this party for nearly
20 years i've been an association and
area officer assembly member mp vice
chair of the party and finally a
treasury minister and also local
government minister and of course
equalities
and i know that we are amazing people
from top to bottom i want to represent
you and i want to fight for you
i voted leave and my maiden speech as an
mp was to celebrate brexit as a vote of
confidence in the united kingdom and
also in the british people
and i'm standing because i want to renew
this party in government and win a
historic fifth term i only decided to
enter this race seven days ago with a
very small volunteer campaign team i am
topping a number of polls and have
beaten six current or former cabinet
ministers imagine what we could achieve
with you the activists and this great
party behind me i have a political
message that is cutting through and
resonating
and i have the courage the clarity and
the conviction to deliver my
conservative provision for britain
to be prime minister to be kirstama and
most importantly for you win the next
election thank you
thank you kemi and then ultimately penny
morsens
good afternoon everyone
we must remember in this contest that
whilst we're choosing a new leader the
nation is watching us choose a new prime
minister
we should be focused on the issues that
matter to them
we should recognize what families and
businesses need
they're facing real quality of life
issues the cost of living
being unable to access a health care
system that they are paying huge amounts
of their salaries into
cost burdens of bureaucracy on business
there is a massive catch-up job to do
postcovid
and huge ambitions to fulfill
post-brexit
and we have to be able to deliver
and that means modernizing whitehall so
it can
so we can move at the speed that
business and science leads us to
it means building a modern economy
fit for the modern world and we need to
focus on growth
we need our tax policy and our supply
side reforms
to deliver that growth and be able to
have our nation compete on the
international stage
and we also need to focus on innovation
investment incentives and
a whole raft of other supply-side
reforms
we also need to be focused on the things
that really will help us level up and we
need to be realistic about how we can do
that and have our ambitions not limited
by what is in the treasury's coffers
we need to deliver excellence in public
services and use both the mandate and
the majority that the public have given
us
and we need to crowd in the independent
sector and drive power down
locally in this contest i've outlined
the principles on which i will make
decisions about tax but i have not made
tax announcements apart from some very
targeted and timely support to help with
the cost of living those decisions are
best taken at a fiscal event
this autumn
and finally my focus will be on ensuring
that all of our citizens can live in
safety and security maintaining our
defence spending and also standing up
those things that will make us the most
resilient nation on earth
we need a return to conservative
policies
to confidence
we have responsible
and capable citizens and they want their
government to be to
thank you penny uh and finally in this
round rishi sunak
thanks paul hi everyone
let me get straight to the point the
stakes at the next election for our
party are the biggest they've been in
recent history
in normal circumstances i don't need to
tell all of you it's a tough job to win
a general election but these are not
going to be normal circumstances having
been in power for 14 years not only do
we need to restore trust rebuild our
economy and reunite our country we also
need to do something that's never been
done before in british political history
and that's when a historic fifth term
the threat of a weak labour party
propped up by the lib dems and the smp
is real with all the risk to our union
and voting system that that brings
the only way to save the country is to
stop that from happening
and i believe that i am the best place
person to help our party beat kirstalma
and secure that victory
but i also have a plan to take our
country in a new direction to build a
better future
now we've talked about a lot about taxes
and spending in this contest so far and
you know where i stand we will deliver
more tax cuts once we've got our house
in order and got a grip of inflation a
lesson margaret thatcher knew only too
well
but that is only the foundation of a
much broader mission
i want the united kingdom to lead the
world in education innovation and
technology to make this the epicenter
for the change that we're seeing in the
global economy
i want families up and down the country
to see tangible change in their
communities with better infrastructure
safer streets and more affordable
housing
i want businesses to see the benefits of
the freedom and flexibilities of brexit
that i voted and campaigned for living
under the laws of our own land
and i want all of us
to feel like we have turned a corner
past covered
past inflation
past delay and disruption
towards growth
and hope
we can create a britain where the
possibilities for the next generation
are better than the last
where everyone has the opportunity of a
second chance where an entrepreneur can
try again where a factory worker can
retrain
we can create a britain where the most
important part about your success is how
hard you work
and we can create a britain where family
is one of the easiest joys not one of
the hardest sacrifices
i want to draw on all wings in our party
to build a government to draw on the
enormous talents and capabilities we
have
because the challenges that we face
are enormous
i believe with all my heart that we can
do better
so in a few weeks time
i hope that i can ask for all of your
permission
to lead our party and country forward
and i hope that you will grant it thank
you
okay rishi thank you very much and uh
thanks to all of you
we're now going over to our uh questions
from the public i should say not just
conservative home readers or
conservative voters but anyone who wants
to put a question
the first one is from david and he is
really this big question about trust and
i'm going to ask it in reverse order to
the opening so the question is
how will you reunite the party and
country win back the trust of the public
and win the next general election and
rishi sudan i need to start with you uh
very conscious of the fact that you
resigned from the government recently
yes thanks paul thanks uh thanks david
for the question uh you you hit on all
the right things which are probably
behind me as you can see because i think
those are the most important things for
all of us to do and i think it starts
with honesty it starts with being honest
with the country about the challenges we
face
and making sure that we don't promise
things that we can't deliver that's how
you start by restoring trust in politics
and we've had a debate on the economy
and taxes and that's very much been my
point of view but i think it goes beyond
that because you also talked about
reuniting the country when we get to
that general election we as
conservatives need to win in lots of
different places whether it's winning in
brexit supporting t side or liberal
leading cheshire and amisham you know i
believe that i am well placed to appeal
in all those places because crucially we
have to beat kirsten in that election to
deliver all the things that we all
collectively believe in
okay
so a penny more than this big question
about trust and unity in the party in
the country
well we have to pull our party together
um and i hope this contest can be the
start of that i want a positive uh
contest i don't want uh mudslinging i
want us all of us candidates uh and our
colleagues to show the nation that we
are building a team together uh without
that teamwork we can't deliver this is
not all about
one particular leader it's about all the
talents of the party being able to
thrive and pull together in the same
direction for the sake of our country
i agree we have to start delivering for
people
it is no point in us saying we are we
actually have to start to do that and we
know that many of our public services
are in a desperate state particularly
because of the pandemic we have a huge
catch-up job to do so we have to
recognize that we need to modernize
whitehall to do that that has got to be
the starting point we cannot continue
what we've been doing because it it
clearly
isn't working
i think the other thing that we also
need to do
is to
recognize that we have to demonstrate we
understand that issues are different in
different parts of the country
what i've shown in the campaign that
i've been running is that i'm attracting
support from young people from women
from red wall from blue wall seats and
all parts of the united kingdom
and i think we also need to create some
national missions to union with people
around but that i think is the starting
point we've got to make this contest
about building a team and we've got to
be talking about the issues that matter
to the public
kami trust and unity what would you do
as conservative leader
i think the most important thing to do
uh to win and retain trust is to keep
promises
uh i think that when we put things in
our manifesto we need to stick to them
i think having multiple u-turns as a
government is incredibly damaging and
means that people don't know whether we
say what we mean and that's why i keep
telling everyone that i am the candidate
and tells the truth making realistic
promises and commitments is one way to
earn and build trust but i also think in
terms of demonstrating integrity it's
show don't tell no one stands as a
dishonest politician but we have to show
that we are honest and straight with
people and we have to go above and
beyond the standards that we apply to
everybody else
i use the example of when i was vice
chairman of candidates and the first
thing i did when i became when i took on
that rule was i threw my husband off the
list because i didn't think it would
look good he was chair of candidates and
he was applying for seats i recognized
that there was a potential conflict of
interest there and even though i wasn't
required to i took additional steps to
show that this was something that i took
seriously
in terms of uniting uh the party and the
country for me the most important thing
is for us to stop calling ourselves
leavers and remainers that vote was six
years ago i think it's time that we
moved on and remember that we are all
one people and we're all uh trying to to
deliver on the same objective certainly
as conservatives i see all of my
colleagues irrespective of how they
voted in the referendum as friends and
as partners i think we need to stop uh
calling looking at things by the view of
north versus south red wall blue wall
young or old or even england versus
scotland it's the language in unity and
inclusivity that matters and that's what
i will do if i'm elected as party leader
uh thank you kemi tom your opening pitch
a few moments ago was about
trust and unity so how would you do it
well the key to delivering trust and
unity is about delivering a change as we
know we need a clean start in order to
show the country not just show the party
that we've started again and that's why
i'm standing because i think having a
clean start being a clean start is all
about demonstrating that we're here to
deliver not just for our party which is
so important but for the whole country
and so for me trust is about
demonstrating that change it's about
demonstrating that we will deliver on
our commitments it's about reaching out
to people and enabling and empowering
people it's about helping people to as
the line goes take back control because
it's about people's lives it's about
your lives it's not about how we control
in westminster it's about what we do at
home and in families and on unity we'll
look
i have spent years campaigning across
the united kingdom i've campaigned in
council elections in northern ireland
i've connected campaigning parliamentary
elections in scotland and general
elections all around the united kingdom
and that unity is about how we talk to
each other how we see each other where
we go how we
approach every issue that we champion as
conservatives and that's why i'm so
proud to be working with jake berry on
northern powerhouse issues as they used
to be called leveling up as they were
once called and a new deal for britain
as it will be called because we can
deliver for the whole of the united
kingdom we can demonstrate the unity
that we need through the actions that we
take
and i'm absolutely committed as your
leader as prime minister to make sure
that the conservative message of unity
of one united kingdom whole integral
safe and secure
will be one that we carry across the
country that generates trust
rebuilds unity
and transforms our country for the
better
thanks tom liz truss
hello liz
i can't
hear you
mute button issues
okay what unites what unites all of us
as conservatives
is that we want the united kingdom to be
successful we want to help our
constituents
deliver on the cost of living crisis
help them make ends meet help growth and
opportunities across the country i think
having a forward-looking positive
economic agenda is a vital part of that
whether you're in scotland wales
northern ireland
in england red wall blue or purple
that is the absolutely vital lynchpoint
and
it is critical
that when we set out our plans we
deliver what we'll say we deliver and in
every single job i've done in government
when i've made commitments i've
delivered on those commitments i said
i'd take on the brexit negotiations when
we haven't been able to get a deal with
the eu i put the northern ireland
protocol bill to parliament because i am
determined to deliver what we promised
the british public and that is the
approach that i would take as prime
minister i won't make false claims
i will be honest with people i will
level about the very difficult situation
we find ourselves in and i will build a
team that goes right across the
conservative party all parts of our
party to show that we have that vital
form of momentum but you've got to walk
the walk as well as talk the talk and
that i think is what i've shown i've
done in the jobs i've held
okay liz thanks very much so straight
into our second question
which talking of the economy is about
the cost of living and it comes from
heather and it's this uh as one of the
most pressing issues
how will you tackle the cost of living
crisis particularly thinking about
energy and fuel bills and i'm just going
to add a coder of my own which is what
would you do about tax
so i'm going to start right in the
middle with kenny
thank you heather
is the cost of living crisis i am not is
uh promising uh big tax cuts and
competing because i think it's important
that we're realistic about the fiscal
situation but i do recognize that a lot
of people are struggling i see it in my
constituency i think one of the quickest
things we could do is look at fuel duty
to reduce that the fuel duty uh
that we have raised as a country in the
treasury is higher than it has been and
so we have we are we have had room to
cut some duties there i also think that
there are some things we should look at
around universal credit uplift and
pension uplift bringing that forward so
those are two things that i would do to
address the cost of living crisis on tax
cuts i am committed to lower personal
and corporate taxes or i am not setting
exactly what rates those would be
because i think that we need to look at
this physical situation in the round and
the consequences of each and every
single penny that we either take from
people or give you back to people
okay uh so uh tom
thanks paul and thanks heather the
question of fuel price
and the question of tax is one that i'm
afraid we're all facing we all feel two
pounds a liter we all feel the extremely
high gas price that we're all paying now
and there are several answers that we
need to look at there are some immediate
ones and that's why i've spoken about
cutting fuel duty and cutting energy
costs at home that's why i've spoken
about welfare uplifts and i've spoken as
well about the way in which we manage
the boiler situation which is affecting
so many peoples finding engineers is a
struggle
and that's why i've also spoken about
our dependence on others because the
dependence that we see on russian energy
in europe is causing price rises here in
the united kingdom the dependence we're
seeing on so many issues abroad is
affecting us here at home and that's why
i'm making the case that what we really
need to be doing is restoring trust with
our neighbors and friends so that we can
work together to lower energy costs and
we can improve the opportunities for
everyone in the united kingdom now we
can do this and this is also about
making sure we deliver for communities
further away from london
further north you go the more you're
going to pay on energy prices and the
more you're going to feel the cold so
before we get to christmas we need a new
leader we need a leader who can restore
trust
who can build back
our
relationship with homes around the
country and can actually deliver the
cuts in prices the cuts in energy costs
that we need and we'll then need an
energy resilience plan to plan for the
future and a 10-year plan for growth to
protect our economy
thanks tom and um penny what would you
do uh as tory leader and prime minister
to alleviate pressure on the cost of
living
well just starting with the the tax
element of your question there paul
although i have uh set out the
principles on which i would be basing my
tax policy i've not made commitments to
particular uh levels i think that's this
this contest is not the right place to
do it but the principles i would be
working under would be those that would
enable the uk to compete
on that environment
i have though uh set out some
timely and
um
limited support measures to help with
cost of living uh for example halving
that on fuel at the pump uh saving you
about 10 pounds every time you fill up
and also
some policies around
raising thresholds for lower and middle
income earners
in line with inflation
those things i think will help but i
think we need to recognize that this
autumn is going to be very difficult for
people uh there will be more that we
need to do and although we can
do more on the supply of uh and our
reserves uh on uh energy for for
households and businesses i think there
are going to be some additional things
we need to do as well as looking at some
of the
uh
structures around how bills are put
together the standing charge and so
forth
but i also think there's more we can do
to
alleviate those pressures on families
and businesses
without actually having to uh uh spend
money
for example if we
really pursue uh some great ideas on uh
on tax simplification
the costs of those savings to businesses
of being tax compliant are are going to
be considerable and probably more than
uh any handouts that uh the the treasury
could uh come up with uh so i think we
have to do more with less we have to
make this easier and remove burdens on
families and uh and businesses uh but
i'm not going to set out uh plans for
corporation tax or any of those other
taxes uh until we have a proper fiscal
event
liz trusts cost of living and energy
prices and tax what do you think
well paul i think we immediately need to
start putting money back into people's
pockets we know that families are
struggling to make ends meet at the
moment so what i would do is reverse the
national insurance rise i opposed it in
cabinet at the time because i thought it
was a mistake i think it's even more of
a mistake now when we're facing such
strong economic headwinds i would also
have a temporary moratorium on the green
energy levy to cut 153 pounds from
people's energy bills and i would also
not
do the corporation tax hikes because i
think it's vitally important that we're
attracting investment into our country
but the big problem we face here
is that the public sector
needs to be growing slower than the
private sector we need higher private
sector growth and we've had anemic
growth for the past two decades so that
is going to take
really strong regulatory reform taking
the full benefits of being able to do
different uh from the eu in areas like
financial services environment better
environmental regulation
better
planning regulation better regulation
about building so that we can get the
economy going so we can get
companies investing in our country and
say we can see people's wages rise with
higher paid jobs because that is
ultimately what we are going to have to
do to solve our problems in the longer
term so i take those immediate steps to
help families who are really struggling
at the moment whilst getting on with the
long-term supply-side reforms that
frankly we've delayed for too long so
that we can see britain become a farce
highly innovative economy
liz thanks very much um so finally um
rishi soon rishi you're the target of
some of this criticism about tax really
uh so what are you going to say so our
number heather asks the the most
important policy question of this
campaign and what the country is looking
at and
the most impressing economic challenge
we face is inflation
inflation is the enemy that makes
everybody poorer and it must be the
government's priority to get a grip of
it
and i i'm not going to do anything that
puts that at risk so i will deliver tax
cuts but i will do so responsibly after
we've got a grip of inflation and i
think that's the right thing to do and
indeed that's what margaret thatcher did
in the early 80s and it's a approach to
the economy that's been supported by
many people familiar with her thinking
now i published a tax plan earlier this
year and it set out my plans for the
future we do need to cut and reform
business taxation we need to do it in a
way that actually drives growth and
productivity getting businesses to
invest more and to innovate more in r d
so we'll do that if i'm elected leader
we also need to reward hard work because
that's a core conservative value which
is why i've put in our plans and paid
for a cut to income tax before the end
of this parliament
on energy
heather knows that this is the biggest
problem that everyone is facing i've
announced lots of things already as a
government that we collectively have
stood behind we have not done a good
enough job of communicating that so we
need to improve improve that to make
sure people understand that the help
that they are getting which is
considerable over the autumn and winter
to help with some of those bills but
that's only a short-term fix what we
also need to do is improve the supply of
energy we have over the long term so
look at new sources of homegrown energy
whether that's the north sea with gas or
offshore wind we need to double down on
all that similarly with home insulation
where we can help save money off
people's bills in relatively short order
by improving and improving energy
efficiency of their homes those are the
type of long-term ways we can help on
the energy side as well as the
short-term fixes
but lastly the most important thing to
say is the best way to help people with
the cost of living and put more money in
their pockets is to make sure that
they're in well-paid jobs so we need to
move people off welfare into work make
sure they've got the skills they need to
get better paid jobs that's a
conservative way to help people and
that's the best long-term way to deal
with this problem
okay rasheed thanks very much and i'm
now on to our second question
which is about defense and security from
lee
and his question is why do you think
that you're best placed
to stand up to putin and what will you
do to support ukraine so i'm going to
start with penny mordent
so i think we should be incredibly proud
of what we've done to support ukraine
and it hasn't just happened overnight
it's happened over many many years
as min af i
bolstered our training operation there
um stepping up the volume and the type
of things that we were doing to to train
them to uh
to make themselves more resilient and to
grow their forces and capability
we've done a huge amount obviously to
support them in weapons but we also
have been helping on the civil defense
side as well so all of the the civil uh
protection
people rescuing individuals after
attacks all of that has been
assisted by this nation
and i've had a great part in that
because of the two departments that i've
particularly been involved in
what i think we do have to do is to be
honest with the british people
about how hard it is as this goes on how
it is going to exacerbate some of the
problems our country and the the world
is facing but i am 100
confident that the british people will
stand behind our strategy on ukraine
putin has to fail uh he cannot gain any
territory he cannot be emboldened uh in
his ambitions at all and there can be no
compromise
in terms of
that fact
my expertise in this area are well known
i have served i've had a naval career
for 12 years i've served as both minaf
and secretary of state for defence at
the cabinet office i rewrote our
nation's resilience strategy and stood
up our
first one hmg defensive cyber policy and
of course sat round the national
security table so i have the expertise
but i also think i'm able to spot the
opportunity in particular situations the
tragedy of afghanistan was that our
country failed to spot the opportunity
of maintaining a presence there and that
is something i would do and finally
we don't look far enough ahead
i would make some changes to how we
horizon scan
the length of time our strategies cover
because it is not serving us well and it
is not making our country the most
resilient national nurse which is what
it needs to be
thanks penny so uh can we bait and lock
uh thank you paul uh so the question was
why my best place to stand up to putin
it's because i more than anyone
understand just how important it is that
the uk remains a force for good in the
world and is seen as a force for good in
the world the threats to our country are
numerous and existential and we need to
show that we are a strong country that
can't be pushed around in every single
opportunity that i was given as a
minister when we were threatened by
opposition parties i stood firm i was
incredibly robust and i did not allow
anyone to smear our reputation or push
us around
that's the sort of attitude that i would
be bringing on the international um on
the international stage it is critically
important that countries around the
world know that we are there to protect
those who cannot protect themselves and
that we look after the vulnerable but we
will not be able to do that if we aren't
strong i believe in strong defense i
think it is important that we continue
to meet our commitments to nato and i
think that when you do all of these
things in the round
uh people like putin who are a threat to
our country and who are looking for
weaknesses at every opportunity will
know that we are not a country to be
trifled with
on ukraine i believe that it is
important because of the vulnerabilities
that they have to continue to support
them i think that a loss uh in that war
would be terrible for us for many years
to come the long-term threat would be
significant and we along with our allies
in the western world should do
everything we can to protect the people
thank you kevin thanks very much
so um tron two gonna i think
you're the only candidate i apologize if
this is wrong because actually being
sanctioned by china what would you do to
stand up to putin and support ukraine
well i've also been sanctioned by putin
so you know i wouldn't like to feel the
chinese were on their own on this uh on
this uh wicket look i don't know if i've
mentioned it before but i i've been in
the army for a while and uh i served for
a number of years on combat operations
in iraq and afghanistan and i've stood
and fought for my country and for our
country for many years and i have been
fighting for our country in parliament
too
since i took over the foreign affairs
committee i have been fighting putin's
russia in parliament i've been calling
out the dirty money that's running
through our system i've been calling out
the problems that we've got in our own
system in not stopping the corrupt
oligarchs who are spreading their dirty
tentacles through our system i've been
calling out the corruption i've been
highlighting the dangers to ourselves
and to our nation this is something i've
been doing consistently and against many
threats and against quite a lot of
criticism even from the government
we need to go further we need to do more
now i was in ukraine earlier this year
and i've met with many ukrainian
officials and military officers in the
past 12 months talking about the
challenges they face now i understand
the combat they're in because i've been
in combat i understand the challenge
they face because i've seen those
challenges now i know what we can do i
know what we must do we must put the
ukrainian people in such a position
that they have the upper hand we must
force putin to realize he is going to
lose now it's not for us
to define what victory means for the
ukrainians it's their land their lives
and their fighting it's for president
zielinski
who's an amazingly courageous individual
who has demonstrated leadership above
and beyond anything we could expect
it's for him and for his country to
define what they're willing to fight for
but it's for us to put them in a
position that they can choose to fight
now they're already demonstrating
enormous courage but we need to increase
the supplies because they're using up
in a day what we're supplying in a week
that's not good enough we need to
increase the support to the ukrainian
people we need to increase our support
of nato already
nato is
doing what it can
but it's doing what it can in places
that are really difficult
what we need to be doing is making sure
that nato is in a stronger position that
means supporting our allies in estonia
lithuania and latvia that's where i was
last year
i was watching
putin use migrants as weapons against
lithuania now that's outrageous using
human trafficking and human slavery
effectively to undermine nato partners
we must stand strong against him we can
stand strong against him
we need to spend i'm sorry but we do we
need to spend more on defense we need to
be absolutely clear to our enemies that
we are committed to standing up against
them we will not back down this is
absolutely existential to us and it's
about defending our people it also i'm
afraid connects to energy if we are not
able to defend ourselves we will find
that prices rise we find that energy
supplies run short and that our enemies
use all the weapons all the tools that
they have at their disposal against them
so for me this is about rebuilding trust
with our allies it's about rebuilding
trust at home it's about investing in
the future of our country and investing
in the industry that builds strength and
then the soldiers that guarantee it
thanks tom rishi sunak what's your view
on defense spending and how would you
manage this transition from the treasury
in your case to
deal with putin and ukraine
thanks uh thanks paul and thanks lee for
the question i i passionately believe
the united kingdom is an enormous force
for good in the world and we should all
be proud of the leadership role that
we've
played not just in this most recent
crisis but over years
in the past when it comes to defense
spending i take it incredibly seriously
in the midst of the coveted pandemic
when we were dealing with lots of things
i made an exception for the ministry of
the defense and the in 2020 i sat down
and made sure that they were provided
with long-term funding certainty
something that no other department had
but we singled out the mod because it
was incredibly important and what we did
was provide them with the biggest uplift
in defence spending since the end of the
cold war that's what i did as chancellor
to deal with all the problems that
people have read about with the
equipment black holes and that they were
grappling with all of that was solved
with the significant uplift and funding
that i approved and i've continued to
support them
with more
weapons and funding for ukraine as tom
alighted on but in terms of standing up
to putin
you know what we have to have done is
put in place some very serious sanctions
that made it difficult for him now i
work very closely with liz and we'll
come to her in a moment but most people
would know the way that we have made him
pay a price primarily is through
economic sanctions and working with liz
we've put together one of the most
significant and far-reaching sanctions
packages that this country's ever done
indeed we've led the world in doing that
and that's me and liz working with our
counterparts around the world to do a
bunch of things targeting russian
financial assets of the state of their
businesses of their individuals and
that's what we've done to make a very
strong
signal of intent and punish them for
their actions looking forward
all i'd say is defense spending is
forecast to rise to two and a half
percent i don't take a an approach to it
which focuses on arbitrary figures for
me i will invest whatever it is required
to keep our country safe so i take a
threat based approach to it and i'm
always thinking about future threats
obviously my background unlike tom is
not in defense but actually as a
backbench mp i wrote a paper
highlighting one of the future threats
to our security the threat to undersea
cables which carry all our data and
information which are increasingly an
object of attack by our enemies in
particular i highlighted russia you know
that paper has now been quoted by three
different uh chief of defense staffs in
various lectures so it gives people some
confidence that i am thinking about the
future threats that this country faces
and i as prime minister will almost make
sure that we invest efficiently to
protect us against them
thank you rishi well liz trust you're
also embedded in this subject why do you
think uh you're the best place of these
five people to stand up to putin and to
support ukraine
what we have led the free world in
standing up to putin and supporting
ukraine in their
need
and weapons to ukraine uh we've led on
sending heavy weapons and we've also led
on sanctions it was at the g7 in
december last year that we agreed with
our colleagues that we would put in
place coordinated sanctions if putin
invaded ukraine we used our intelligence
to expose what his plans were we
coordinated international allies to call
out ukraine we had sorry to call out
russia we had russia kicked out
of the uh council of europe we had them
kicked out of the human rights council
and i personally have
made sure working with my colleagues
around the world that there is no
compromise lots of people were talking
about a deal where bits of ukrainian
territory could be
given or compromised with russia we've
been very clear that isn't happening and
that is now the consensus view at both
g7 and nato because of the strong stand
the united kingdom and our allies have
taken now we need to do more
we need to send more weapons to ukraine
we need to send more heavy weapons we
need to encourage our allies to do more
we also need to put more sanctions on
ukraine i think it's unacceptable
that the european continent is still
buying gas from russia which is funding
putin's war machine we've got
to learn the lesson for other countries
as well we cannot become strategically
dependent on authoritarian regimes and
that applies to china as well as it
applies to russia we need to make sure
that we're working more closely in
trading with our allies and friends
building what i describe as a network of
liberty
and on the subject of defense spending i
don't think we do spend enough on
defense
during the cold war we were spending
four or five percent of our gdp on
defense we took our eye off the ball we
made it easier for aggressors to
save a rattle we saw that before the
invasion russia were building up their
tanks on the ukrainian border we can't
let that happen again so my view is we
need to be at least at three percent of
gdp by the end of this decade and we
need to work with our allies to increase
that level right across nato because
if putin heaven forbid is successful in
ukraine he will not stop there we know
the baltic states are under threats we
know that eastern europe is under threat
and all the great
change that we saw happen in the late
80s and early 90s those people gaining
freedom again for the first time in
decades could be lost and that doesn't
just threaten
freedom and democracy in europe it
threatens it in the uk and around the
world so this for me is absolutely
existential and we need to put our money
where our mouth is
okay liz thanks very much i'm gonna go
to our third question which is on this
crucial issue of housing
how would you propose to solve the
heising crisis and help more people into
home ownership i mean i'd add a rider of
my own which is the government seems to
have had enormous problems getting
anything substantial housing through the
commons so i'm going to start with
tom tougenhart
thank you very much well look you don't
need me to tell you that housing is a
huge problem in the southeast but it's
actually a huge problem across the
united kingdom and this is one of those
areas where we really need to look at
what a conservative solution is now we
know what a labor solution would do a
labor solution would concrete over the
whole country and leave us with
socialist homes that are owned by the
state and we can rent on a temporary
basis that's not what we want
what we want is people around our
country who are able to build homes and
build families within them to grow
families to grow hope and to grow lives
we can do that
but it means investing properly around
our whole country it means a new deal
for britain it means a clean start and
it means restoring trust because
actually all of this
all of this is to do with the confidence
that we have in our own communities the
confidence that we have in our own
people
now i believe in britain and i'm sure we
all do
but i'm also going to give britain the
hope that it can regrow because actually
a 10-year plan for growth is going to
focus on a fairer economy
a stronger economy and a more resilient
economy and that's going to be built on
things like housing
now when i have spoken about where we're
going to get the money from i've looked
at the solvency to regulation that's
taken too long to break away from europe
on we need to take the brexit
opportunity that it offers get 100
billion pounds out of dead money and put
it into live communities and we can do
that we can turn it into homes we can
turn it into jobs and we can turn it
into opportunity
and that's where i'm going to be focused
because giving people a start in life
giving people the ability to own their
own home
is fundamentally conservative margaret
thatcher did it
and transformed lives we can do it and
we can do it again and i'm going to do
it when i'm leading this country when
i'm leading our party
thanks um
so
penny morgan your view on solving the
housing crisis
so the first thing i would say is the
thing that doesn't help get houses built
is
targets
and i know this from my my own local
constituency
that has obviously had housing targets
and out of
the last five years not one house has
been built apart from one year
and
there are some real reasons why that is
we have some general problems across the
country with regard to competition
between
developers the fact we've got uh lots of
housing um planning permissions granted
but uh
the actual developments themselves
stifled but there are lots of other
reasons why
we we are failing to get the volume of
houses built that we need every year um
but they're different in different
places
and as well as tackling those big issues
that we'll know about with regard to
competition
and as well as ensuring that we are
being very ambitious in new areas i
think there's some you know new uh uh
towns which we uh need to uh to build we
need to be focusing on brownfield sites
which are difficult to to get back into
uh into use for free the housing or
other
uses
but there are all sorts of other leaders
in government that unless we address we
will not unlock this so just to give you
one example the valuation office some of
the valuation offices rebanding policies
are stifling much needed development and
also development that would take the
pressure off housing stock for example
shared living accommodation for young
professionals wanting to get on the
housing letter ladder so i think we have
to take a a different approach to this
um rishi i'm sure will smile because i
he knows i've been writing to him for
about
two years
uh about about these sorts of issues but
the valuation office might sit with him
but in fairness to him the policy
doesn't so unless we've got something
that's looking across the whole of
government at these issues
we're never going to get where we need
to be it's uh and the final point i
would make is uh is about planning
departments
we have very little capacity in planning
demand departments and i don't just mean
in terms of numbers of people i mean the
actual skill sets the ambition the
vision and the support for them
i'm a big fan of of neighborhood
planning forums if you look they are
actually coming up with more ambitious
housing schemes
than their local authorities and the
targets that we are enforcing on them so
i say let a thousand flowers bloom build
capacity in housing departments get a
task force in government that
relentlessly focuses on increasing the
number of housing
houses that are being built and then get
all parts of government pulling in the
right direction that is the only way we
are going to actually meet the demand
out there and give a population any
chance particularly young people of
getting on the housing ladder
okay um
kevin bazenok
thank you paul uh i have been a minister
in the housing department now for a
while and i have seen the acute housing
crisis from a different perspective as a
constituency mp
the issue we have is around supply
however we are unable to supply the
homes because it is very difficult for
communities to accept them because of
the way that the homes are delivered
penny is absolutely right when she talks
about housing targets it scares people
when we talk about building 300 000
homes because it sounds like all these
homes are coming next door to them and
one of the things that they really want
to see is the infrastructure that's
going to support the host we have not
been good at delivering the
infrastructure for housing before the
homes are built we need to do that and
it isn't just physical infrastructure
like roads and bypasses it's things like
gps and schools people want to live in
nice communities they want homes not
just houses but we keep talking about
houses as if they are a commodity rather
than something that people need to
survive and i think we can do better
than that i think that there are uh
issues around developer oligopolies we
have lost quite a lot of small to
medium-sized builders which means that
many of those large corporations that
deliver homes build the sorts of homes
that people don't actually want to live
in they're ugly people get trapped in
them there are lots of issues around
leasehold and these are these are things
that we have been uh solving within the
department for leveling up uh housing
and local government there is also the
issue about the asset bubble uh this
does relate to the economy with all of
the quantitative easing uh that's been
happening for well over 10 years now
people feel that housing is the only
safe place to put their money we need to
change that and free our homes so that
they're not just investments for people
who already have homes so tackling buy
to let's uh especially in places on the
south coast where people have uh second
homes but those local people are not
able to purchase homes there so dealing
with affordability is also critical and
we do also need better planning we need
to look at migration look at numbers
that uh particular communities have to
accept when we're
when we're sorting out planning for
homes penny's also right about the issue
with planning departments it is very
difficult for the planning departments
to fight the very very well played paid
planning qcs who are able to manipulate
it
when we were in the department we had an
accurate in biden and it met stood for
beauty infrastructure development
environment democracy environment
neighborhoods that's what we believe can
be done to uh deliver the homes that
this country wants and that's exactly
the sort of agenda that i would have in
order to sort out the housing crisis
thank you all right okay tell me thank
you very much um let's trust a lot of
talk so far from the other candidates
about local control opposition to
targets infrastructure and all that
some people say
um if they're of a cynical mind all this
simply means nothing is going to be
built and there will be no change
so what's your view
well first of all it's vitally important
that we give more people the opportunity
of home ownership and i think it's very
very worrying that people become older
and older before they're able to afford
their first home and i think that's a
problem for our country and how people
feel and whether they feel they've got a
stake in our society but it's also a
very it's an electoral problem for the
conservatives when younger people
simply aren't able to afford a home
anymore they're not part of that
property owning democracy that has been
so critical uh to us gaining support at
elections and of course the right to buy
was the great example of where we opened
up uh home ownership to many many more
people i think one of the problems is
that we've taken a one-size-fits-all
policy approach to housing and we need
different policies in different parts of
the country
the situation in cornwall is very very
different to that in london
very very different to that in the north
of england or scotland
and
in our cities i think we should be
building up more
we should make more of the space we have
in our countryside in rural areas i'm a
supporter of allowing incremental
expansion of villages rather than these
massive targets
that land on the back
of local councils i also think we need
to look at
housing together with
industry infrastructure as
as communities rather than just housing
estates plonked in the middle of nowhere
with no discernible facilities or
infrastructure to support them and i
think that's the way we get support of
local communities but what i wanted to
say is we're not going to be able to
have a successful planning policy
if we don't have the support of all of
the conservative party i don't want to
see another planning war like we we've
had before so it's very very important
that we
have policies that command local consent
that local people can support because
they know that it's going to help their
children
their grandchildren their friends get on
the housing ladder and that's how we
need to develop that policy
thank you liz rishi sunak
thanks uh paul
we're all conservatives and we believe
in home ownership and we want to make
sure that people can fulfill that dream
of owning their own home and sadly
far too many young people can't anymore
and that's something that we have to
figure out a way to solve kemi's right
though it's not an easy problem we
should be honest about that because
getting the consent for the number of
homes we need is is a challenge
there are a few things that we can focus
on some of them have been touched on one
is brownfield we do have a decent amount
of brownfield land in in the uk so we're
now spending more money to figure out
how to unlock that and remediate it
the second is urban densification where
in our cities we're much less dense and
lots of other places around europe and
it's easier there to build more housing
which we need to do more of one of our
fantastic colleagues is a chat called
richard bacon and for a long time he's
been talking about modular building
which is again something we should do
it's something that we don't do in this
country at all and it sounds a bit odd
flat-packed housing but lots of
countries around the world use more of
it and it lowers the cost of housing
dramatically someone touched on small
and medium-sized builders they've
disappeared from the market we need to
get them back in and there's some
questions about how we do that and then
lastly land banking which we've looked
at time and time again and making sure
that we have a system where large
developers can't hog the land instead of
it being released for house building i
guess the last thing i would say as well
is look we're conservatives we believe
in ownership now we also have a very big
social housing budget that the
government supports so one of the the
things that robert generate did very
well was start to shift
that budget in the direction of
ownership so we didn't just have social
tenants who were renting we used those
monies to help them buy that home and we
did it incrementally over time and
instead of forcing developers just to
build affordable social housing for rent
we also said to them you have to build
some that people could own and i think
that was a philosophical difference we
have with the labour party because we
believe in supporting home ownership and
not just keeping people in rented social
accommodation now that we we get lots of
people don't like that and but we need
to make sure that we stick up for that
because ownership is something as a
value is really important to us as a
party
thanks very much rishi we're now going
to go to a completely different sort of
question as we've had
questions of a more personal nature
coming in from those who've submitted
them so
peter asked
if this is an interview to become prime
minister what is your greatest weakness
and how would you overcome this
so um
kept me better
thanks peter um
that's a great question
uh
i think my greatest weakness is probably
allowing my sense of humor to look like
i'm flippant about issues
and i'm someone who thinks
and
being really really difficult
submissions
i do recall certain occasions um when i
said things were
just me being a bit jokey people were
either offended or thought i wasn't
taking them seriously and so that is
something which i have um worked on and
now i'm very careful about how i use my
words especially in parliament at the
dispatch box especially on the media i
think it is really important that
politicians present a seriousness to the
public because we're dealing with so
many difficult questions and they need
to know that we are on their side and
that it's not just something that we're
doing for ourselves or is a bit of a lot
so that's a weakness um which i know i
do have and which i work on every moment
and i hope that i've been able to
demonstrate that uh in this
particular hostings but also throughout
the course of my career as a member of
parliament
uh thanks kevin um
rishi sunak
that thanks uh thanks paul i no i i
think most people know i probably have a
reputation for working hard and getting
across the details i think you've got to
make sure that in these jobs especially
the more senior you get that you don't
let perfect be the enemy of the good and
part of what i've had to do over time
and i'm constantly working at is getting
that balance right between across the
detail and understanding every aspect of
something and then realizing
i know as much or i've done as much as i
need to on that and my time is better
spent elsewhere so that's something that
you can constantly get better at but
that's something that i'm always working
on
liz truss
well i think in the past paul is fair to
say i've sometimes been excessively over
enthusiastic and sometimes i have to
reign myself in and try and do a bit
less and make sure that we are 100
focused and that is what i i think we
need to do now we need to focus on
getting the economy going and not try
and do too much
and penny what would you say your your
greatest weaknesses
i was tempted to say um uh burmese cats
as i have four and introducing them into
number ten would might present some
challenges with uh with larry but um
i think
everyone has strengths and weaknesses i
think i
uh
i've learned over the years to to be
able to delegate uh to become uh more
effective but i think all of us um are
going to need to build a team of all the
talents in the party we all have
different backgrounds we all have
different strengths and weaknesses but
the team is what hasn't been at the
heart of a government and uh it's got to
be less about
the just the person in that top job it's
got to be everyone around the cabinet
table and really empowered ministers of
state with very clear deliverables
and a timetable and that is the only way
we're going to get things going
all right penny thanks so much and uh
finally tom twogenheart
well i know this is going to surprise
you but i i may talk about the army a
little bit too much which uh which is
possibly possibly a weakness i mean it
was incredibly formative for my life and
it did teach me a lot about
leadership and team building and all the
things i think are necessary but it
would be wrong to think that it's a
one-size-fits-all i know
i know that it's not for everybody and i
do know that uh that we do have to find
many other organizations uh that help in
different ways and one of the things i
definitely celebrate in number 10 is of
course not just the uniform services
like the ambulances and our medical
provision but also the businesses and
the communities and the families that
the ducey and marchand are absolutely
essential to supporting us so restoring
trust with them and getting a clean
start on that
emphasis on the army may be something i
need to work on
okay tom thanks look i'd love to have
had time for much more which we haven't
got but we now must move into our
closing statements of about a minute
each i'm going to do them in the same
order that we uh did the opening remarks
which means that liz truss will
start friends and friends and colleagues
we need to deliver for our country
people are struggling with the cost of
living crisis we need to make sure we
revive our towns and cities across the
country we only have two years before a
general election
i'm a prime minister that could hit the
ground running with a clear plan about
how we deliver to turn the economy round
to get all parts of our country going
and also to make sure that we continue
to stand up against putin in his
appalling war in ukraine and continue to
deliver all the promises and
opportunities of brexit i'm somebody
who's shown in every job i've done i
deliver i do what i say i will do i keep
my promises
i can go in i can defeat
ed davey and kierstama at the next
election by making sure we are
demonstrating
we have delivered delivered delivered
for the british people
liz thanks very much and next uh tom
tuggenheart
thanks paul and thanks for the
opportunity to talk so many conservative
members today
i'm going to lead us in a new direction
because i think we can deliver a clean
start i think we can deliver a new party
a new drive that is going to change the
way we speak to the british people
in the elections next year for councils
across our country and the year after in
the general election we need to win we
need to defeat stama sturgeon and davey
and we can do it we absolutely can do it
we can only do it if we get a clean
start now i know that this is going to
be difficult and we need to deliver
but by delivering for the british people
we will demonstrate again why the
conservative party is the natural party
of government and we will not hand this
great country over to labor and labour's
failures we won't allow the separation
of our union and we will defend our
country as i have defended it all my
life
thanks tom and uh kemi bavenock
thank you paul um i started out uh my
opening statement by saying i would tell
you the truth and i would show you who i
was and i hope that conservative home
readers have seen a little bit more
about me that shows that i have the
courage the clarity and the conviction
to be the prime minister of this country
but the truth is in 2024 we would have
been in government for 14 years
we will need a fresh face we will need
to renew in government i have
ministerial experience i do not have
cabinet experience but that means that i
don't have the baggage of many of the
decisions which we've taken over the
last few years i will be able to take
the country in a new direction but we
need to be honest with the british
people about the challenges that lie
ahead i'm the right person to do that i
think that we need a smarter smaller
nimble estate only a conservative
government can deliver that and in 2024
i will be able to win back those seats
that we lost to the by-elections but
also hold on to all of the wonderful
colleagues we have in our parliamentary
party and have a bold vision for the
future thank you
yeah thank you kenny penny mordent
well thank you paul and conservative
home for the for the chance to speak to
you today
i'll take the the disagreements that uh
we have between uh the your your
panelists today any day over labor's
policies and the direction that they
would take this country in
we as conservatives we're leveling up
labor would level down
conservatives would deliver a brexit
dividend labor will make that impossible
so we need to win at the next general
election and what all the polling shows
is that you can only win with me
in every poll in our party and in the
country i top it i win against kia
stammer in london i poll the highest in
both red wall and blue walls seats
i lead with women with young people and
i also have the best reach in scotland
so i have some questions for you
do you want to win the next general
election or do you want to hand
everything that we have achieved to the
labour party
do you want a new approach to leadership
which is less about the leader and more
about all of us
do you want to restore positive politics
back into our party
and do you want to enjoy pmqs and unite
this party and take the fight to labour
i do
which is why i'm standing in this
contest
me and finally rishi sunak
thanks paul and thanks everyone for
joining us today and thank you also for
the incredible support that you give our
party up and down the country
the next prime minister faces huge
challenges we need to restore trust in
our politics rebuild our economy and
reunite our country
we must seize the opportunities of
brexit but we also need to do something
that's never been done before in british
political history and that's when a
historic fifth term
i believe i can deliver on all of these
areas
you've all seen me in action over the
past two years and you know that i will
bring honesty seriousness and competence
to government
i'm prepared to give everything i have
in service to our nation and that is why
i'm standing to be the next leader of
the conservative party and your prime
minister
thank you
thank you richie very much uh and in
closing i really want to make three lots
of thanks
uh first to the candidates who joined us
today and uh we wish you all well on
your onward journey intern next week and
this evening's tv hustings which may or
may not be more decorous than these
uh next i won't naturally want to thank
all um
uh conservative home readers for joining
us and pay my own thanks to my fellow
members of conservative home staff for
organising this event
and finally thank all of you whether
you're conservative home readers or not
for joining us this afternoon thank you
very much
[Music]
you